- [Voiceover] We've now seen a couple
of examples of balancing
chemical equations.
And we've seen that, okay, if let's say,
we're trying to balance this
equation right over here
and we started with the carbons.
I have two carbons on the reactant side.
They're both sitting in
this ethylene molecule.
And so I would want two
carbons on the product side.
And right now, I only have one
carbon on the product side.
And so what we've done
is let's just put a two
out front here and so now we have two
for every molecule of ethylene
and we're not done balancing
this chemical equation yet.
We're now producing two
molecules of carbon dioxide.
But one thing that you
might have been thinking,
"Why put this big two out front
"of the entire carbon dioxide,
"I like the way these little
subscript little twos look,
"so why not put a two right over there. "
And the reason why you can't do that
is that's actually changing the molecule.
It's no longer carbon dioxide,
it's now this bizarre thing that
doesn't really exist in nature.
Which is a C2O2 thing.
You're actually changing the reaction
when you're doing that.
When you're balancing chemical reactions,
the reaction itself is,
even before it's balanced is describing
something that happens.
When it's unbalanced, it just doesn't
have the numbers right in terms
of number of molecules.
So the only thing that you can
change when you're changing these
is the number of molecules.
You can't change the number of
constituents within the molecule.
And that's why we do not
change these subscripts.
And if you want to visualize
it a little bit differently,
let's draw each of these molecules
So ethylene looks like this.
Double bond carbons.
Then each carbon is
bonded to two hydrogens.
Notice you have two
carbons and four hydrogens.
Molecular oxygen, O2.
Looks like this.
It's oxygen doubled bonded to oxygen.
And then you have carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is a carbon, double bonded,
to two oxygens each.
And then finally, you have water.
Finally, water, actually I'm going to do
this in a slightly different color.
Your water right over here,
this is an oxygen bonded to two hydrogens.
So let me write the plus signs there.
So plus is right over there.
So if you were to
somehow write a subscript
of two right over there, you would somehow
be changing the structure,
you would be changing
what this molecule is.
As opposed to that, which
we don't want to do,
we want to say, we're definitely
producing carbon dioxide.
We're definitely producing carbon dioxide,
but how many carbon dioxides do we produce
for each molecule of ethylene?
And so that's where we say,
"Okay, we have two carbons here,
"we want two carbons here."
We don't want to change
the actual structure here,
so let's write the two out front.
So we're going to have two of these.
Or if you want to do it,
if you want to have it more visual,
you could write it,
okay, we're just going to
have another molecule here.
We're just going to have another molecule.
So now we've balanced the carbons,
two carbons on the reactant side.
Two carbons on the product side.
And then you go to the hydrogens.
Say, "okay, we have four hydrogens here,
"we only have two here."
Well, what if we had two
of these water molecules?
So, let's draw another
water molecule here.
So O H, and actually let me write
this right over here, so
now we have two of these.
And now we have two of these.
And now we want to balance the oxygens.
So let's see, on this side
we only have two oxygens.
On this side we have one, two,
three, four, five, six oxygens.
In order to balance it, we're going to
have six oxygens on the reactant side.
We need three of these molecules.
So, another one and another
one right over there.
And now we're all balanced.
We have two carbon atoms on both sides.
Carbons, carbons.
We have four hydrogen atoms on both sides.
Here they're in the ethylene,
here they're in the waters.
And then we have six
oxygen atoms on both sides.
And here some of the oxygens
are in the carbon dioxides,
some of them are in the waters.
And here, they're all in
the molecular oxygens.
But notice, we didn't change the
actual structure of the molecules.
We just changed the number
of molecules we have and
that's what these coefficients in front of
these molecular formulas represent.